on est à 3 8 voient leur quotidien
bouleversé par l'arrivée de deux femmes
une jeune photographe mandaté pour
interviewer des témoins d'un feu de
forêt meurtrier
une octogénaire ca décide de venir rien
su c'est pas juste pour déranger dans le
bourg
c'est parce qu'elle s'appelle vraiment
quelque chose qui il se dégage du film
beaucoup de tendresse de délicatesse et
de lumière c'est comme si tout le monde
se rencontre ensemble puis le bois cet
univers l'a77 tendresse la cette douceur
lot 6 mm ben ça fait que les jeunes se
rend compte dans ce pays évolue ici tu
jeu qui s'était isolé du monde pour
vivre en pays sans souffrir évoluer
prouve que l'amour n'a pas d'âge j'avais
envie de botter j'avais envie de
d'espoir j'avais envie de tendre la main
peut être porteur bagages qu'ont vécu
mais 30 prend quelque chose de pouce
s'effacer de voir ça mieux pour la suite
des choses c'est moche leur façon d'être
le plus autonome possible très très fort
et se trouve d'un côté du film qui fait
que les personnes âgées sont en avant et
sont pas des des espèces de perdants ces
hommes là ont fait des choix le choix de
vieillir autrement différemment et de
nos jours c'est une question qu'on se
pose beaucoup comment vieillir c'est un
film qui permet avec poésie et beaucoup
de d'amour de réfléchir à cette question
là tout est clair
vraiment un très bon dans le film est
servi par une remarquable distribution
d'une grande justesse l'enclos tome
c'est que c'est un c'est un chien vous
le dire raté c'est pas possible pas de
talent mais s'est accroché quelque part
dans la consommation d'alcool dans les
bars et tout piste est un excessif pour
lui de changer darbo comme ça c'est une
bouée de sauvetage
le film adapté du roman à succès de
jocelyne saucier sera présenté en
première mondiale au festival du film de
toronto
on a vécu des moments très forts il ya
des moments je te manque henry me hamani
il fait des chansons et on était au
moteur quelques personnes il me fait
pleurer pas pressée cette affaire
c'était sa dernière scène de tournage et
le voit qu'il ya 14 sanglots on se sert
dans les bras puis me dis merci tu sais
pas ça va être quoi la finalité du
projet du film mais ce que tu as vécu je
me dis mais c'est déjà énorme
il pleuvait des oiseaux prendra
l'affiché tous étant ici n'est bien
alexandre char tirée du canada montréal